what do you think love is you're just
like romantically going away to Venice
like every year and that's like like no
a relationship requires a lot of
deliberate work and things like hold on
hold on things like chores are where
relationships start to break down and
it'll steamroll into bigger things like
a guy not doing chores ever might be a
guy that you don't want to anymore
and then you not having sex ever might
be you guys just don't get along anymore
and then like 3 months into it you
hate each other you don't know
why and you're not sleeping together
even you're not having any sex you don't
do anything together and it starts over
small but anybody that's been in
any relationship long term I don't know
how old you guys are but if you've been
in real relationships long term these
little things will pile up and
kill you